And today,
we're continuing our time management masterclass
with news you can use.
We've all been worrying more this year.
Oh my God, that's all I do is worry,
stress, worry.
(Drew groaning)
But how do you deal with that?
I don't want to sit there.
(Drew groaning)
I want, like, actionable help.
And "The New York Times" suggests making time to worry,
to get back to the rest of your day.
They say scheduling 15 minutes to freestyle worry
and then get over it, rip the anxiety bandaid off.
And they also suggest resetting
with a special type of breathing.
I do agree with that, see,
I have breath written on my arm.
And guess what?
I still forget.
You breathe in rocking forward,
and you breathe out rocking back.
This is me normally.
(Drew groaning)
All right, so they call this rock and roll breathing.
All right.
But, I prefer Van inhaling.
(Drew groaning)
If,
if mornings are more of your stumbling block,
then this one really speaks to me, I have to say,
try waking up with the sun, or at least a mini, fake one.
"Yahoo! News" reports people are turning
to sunrise light alarm clocks to help get out of bed easier.
You set when you want the sun to rise,
and then it slowly brightens to wake you up.
Or you could just use nature alarms clock,
which is my children.
Although my kids are old enough now
that they totally sleep in past when we're all supposed to.
That's the irony, parents.
You literally wake up at 4:00 AM, which I've always done
for work anyway, but it never gets any easier.
You get up at 4:00 AM, and then the minute your kids start
to be able to sleep till eight, they got to get up
at six for school.
It is sadistic!
My child finally wants to be lazy and sleep in,
and you make me get up and get out.
It's like, you never get off the hamster wheel!
One way some parents approach time management during
at-home learning was a daily schedule,
like this color-coded one that went viral on social media.
That is not how it's gone for me and my life.
And I'm just wondering, you color-coded wonder,
how do you do it?
And Today.com says that tons of other parents
are actually feeling, apparently, the same way I am,
and sharing their more realistic schedules,
like this one from LawyerKelly.
(upbeat music)